hey greg it's a big day of breaking news
and we have a ton to get to the white
house struggling to deal with the surge
in covent cases after the president
repeatedly promised to shut down the
virus restrictions are coming back in
blue states as a top official says one
mandate could be made permanent and the
white house playing clean up over a
kamala harris interview that went
completely off the rails but first
president biden's agenda implodes after
moderate senator joe manchin says he's a
no on the massive buildback better
spending plan the squad going nuclearly
over that
we all knew that senator manchin
couldn't be trusted
you know the the excuses that he just
made
i think are complete
let mr manchin explain to the people of
west virginia why he doesn't have the
guts to stand up to powerful special
interests he is obstructing the
president's agenda we are not going to
let people
play these games anymore because they
are relying on norms of the old boys
club senator manchin calling out the
president's staff for the breakdown
after gensake accused him of betrayal
the press secretary trying to strike a
softer tone but sticking by her harsh
statement last night i think the
lengthy statement that i issued
yesterday outlined pretty specifically
um the events of the last few weeks and
uh it was important
to the president and to all of us to
make that clear to the american people
we don't have regrets about
aggressively communicating about it and
making sure people understand that if we
don't pass this legislation costs for
the american people will go up and
economic growth projections will not go
in the right direction if there's one
thing we love at the five it's a media
montage here's some media reaction
immediately after joe manchin broke that
news on fox news sunday with bret baer
some breaking news
senator manchin has just said that he is
a firm no on this legislation
manchin is a mercurial person to be
dealing with from people i've talked to
within the white house we know this to
be true
and he you know may want to be a king
maker in some ways when it comes to this
legislation this is joe manchin wanting
to extend the joe manchin show period
so they say they want to continue on and
see if they can get him to come around
but how about this for persuasion
tactics i
really enjoyed that audible gasp it
sounded like somebody was getting a foot
massage maybe tubin was around but that
gasp tells you how emotionally invested
uh the media is in this decision they
were never debating the merits or the
contents of the bill they just wanted a
victory at any cost never mind what it
would do to inflation and everybody knew
it would be a disaster uh and they
didn't care about what was buried in the
bill it was just kind of a naked tell
when you heard that whose side they were
on and then you sit there and you go
like okay
um whose fault is this because we just
saw that the squad was just about on
every single show so it wasn't like
people were keeping them quiet they had
every moment an opportunity to explain
why this bill should be the best thing
since sliced bread so you can't blame
mansion you actually have to blame
the democrats like joe biden who did not
have the guts to stand up to the
militant progressive wing of their party
who turned an infrastructure
infrastructure bill into a candy land of
marxist you know dreams and uh junk
science and junk economics lastly it's
like if you think about if you think
about
the what liberals consider heroes these
day obviously bernie sanders but you
have you know you have like lynn chaney
you have adam kinzinger you got john
mccain these are all these people that
like stood up and speak truth to power
mansion just did the same thing why is
he considered not part of the the cool
group i mean when mccain did it it
wasn't really a non-principled rebellion
it was because he just didn't like trump
mansions manchester united think of when
mccain voted for obamacare yeah yeah i
praised him then yeah exactly so and
then here you have you have manchin
doing a principled stance and and uh
they're all pissed off about it but they
didn't seem to be that pissed when lynn
chaney and kinzinger and mccain are all
doing it because you know trump evil
orange man okay um what about the biden
agenda what does it spell um i uh first
of all wha what the hell am i doing here
i'm sitting in a geraldo's chair
what's that i said you can curse on the
fire i can't i am allowed right seven
seconds i didn't wear a tie i think that
yeah i was taking the day off or the
afternoon off anyway i think if you were
paying attention to the case at hand
senator manchin made his intentions
clear the entire time over the summer
when chuck schumer said i'm good for 1.5
trillion and then through the
negotiating process he up to 1.7
trillion there was a report today that
he went to the white house the other day
and said i'll get a 1.8 i don't know if
that's true or not this just was
reported september 29th and dana we
talked about this earlier in the show a
mansion put out a statement he said what
i made clear
is that spending trillions more on new
and expanded government programs where
he can't even pay for the essential
social programs like social security and
medicare is the definition of fiscal
insanity he's always mentioned means
testing he's always mentioned work
requirements
without a and b there you're just you're
back to welfare in a significant way
built into this bill during that
interview with brett yesterday
manchin mentioned a hearing from 10
years ago it was joint chiefs chair
michael mcmullen i think it was 2011.
and he was asked the question what's the
biggest danger to america and his answer
was our national debt well in 2011 our
national debt was at 14 trillion dollars
today we're at 29 tr we've easily
doubled that since then mansion hasn't
changed he has felt this the entire time
why did this fail
if you want to find faults
look at the president and look at
democrats in congress
with a 50-50 senate and a four-seat
majority in the house they overplayed
their hand and now they're stuck with
them now second they're also i think
being quite
you know condescending to the people of
west virginia just take a listen to
senator manchin what he said on a local
radio show today
surely to god we can move one person
sure that we can badger and beat one
person up surely we can get enough
protesters to make that person
uncomfortable enough they'll just say
okay i'll vote for anything just quit
well guess what i'm from west virginia
i'm not from where they're from and they
can just beat the living crap out of
people and think they'll be submissive
period digging you're always sticking up
for rural america and west virginia has
a mostly rural state alexandria
ocasio-cortez couldn't win one county in
the state of west virginia and they made
the critical mistake of underestimating
somebody because of where they're from
and
people from the south have historically
used that to their advantage it's like
please assume that i'm stupid because i
talk funny please assume that um i you i
you can get one over on me easily
because i'm from virginia or west
virginia and then you sit back and you
watch there as i've said before their
pomposity melt into horror when they
realize they've lost
but these temper tantrums that they had
on national tv and i'm talking about aoc
and her clique uh since when do temper
tantrums make you look strong
they look weak they're a party
controlled by petulant children verrucka
salts i want it and i want it now
they're mad and they're stomping and
they're blinded by ideology and they
this is not the work of pragmatic people
danger is inside mansion said this on
that radio interview that he said it's
not the president it's the staff it's
the progressive staff ron klain and the
people he hired who are pushing uh this
far left-wing agenda at a time when the
you know medicare is running out of
money
so
wall street journal wrote today in the
editorial like is he gonna
if he wants to make a pivot he's got a
jettison
he says today and everybody uh lawrence
that he and biden together had an
agreement that they were going to do a
joint
statement saying we're going to push
this off we're going to do it in march
or april and then to manchin said well
but the white house then put out a
statement blaming him and that's when he
decided that's enough
um i'm compelled to believe manchin
because he's been consistent
and i also think
you know and that statement from jin
saki calling manchin essentially a liar
the audacity i mean
joe biden
compass should be manchester based on
what they promised during the
presidential campaign remember back on
the campaign
barack obama got involved with the race
after saying behind the scenes that joe
was a joke he forced buddha judge out
klobuchar out because they were afraid
that someone like
socialist bernie was gonna get the race
and so they forced all these people out
because joe was the guy
but joe changed once georgia happened he
went from being monitored joe to saying
look i think we can actually be
progressed bernie flipped and said oh he
may be the most progressive president
aoc flipped in the whole squad coalesced
behind joe biden but they didn't do that
with mansion and so i think what you're
looking right now is that you know the
political compass of joe biden used to
be joe manchins and now he's trying to
pretend like joe chang joe manchester
when he really was the one to change and
i think the voters see this and i think
this is why the biden agenda is dead
because he never really had a compass
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else